i i think with you though people like
might be timid to come up because you
might just roast the [ __ ] out of them if
they come wrong or something like that
yeah
i think that i think that i'm no i i
just tease people if they're being yeah
like i went to this thing the other day
right it was just this thing that was
disguised as a brunch and it just turned
out to be this big marketing meeting it
was [ __ ] hilarious
so i'm sitting there and i'm eating this
lamb chop and this guy comes up to me
and starts talking to me and i just
looked at him i was like you know you
had three hours and 55 minutes to not
talk to me when i was eating a lamb chop
i'm gonna be here for four hours
can i just eat this thingy are you gonna
keep asking me right after i took a bite
he was another comedian he laughed and
he's a friend of mine and everything
like that but then of course he rolled
with me he's like no man i'm gonna talk
to you through this whole [ __ ] lamp
job then it became fun and it didn't
bother me because it became a bit
but if somebody's just doing it then
it's annoying so i found with people
like that i mean that you know
it's cool that they they they want to
talk to you and that type of stuff so
like you always have to be like okay
somebody could not be doing this but the
payoff then is i'm selling no tickets
and i'm back to that you know sitting in
that [ __ ] one bedroom apartment with
my ikea furniture
yeah and all kinds of rug available for
yoga because i don't have any money
um so i would rather have this existence
but the happy medium of that selling
tickets right and living a great life is
wearing a mask
that's why i wish i was asian because i
could get away with it because they've
been wearing them for like the asians
they've been wearing them since [ __ ]
stars they used to wear them on the
plane when they had a cold just because
they had a cold and the level of
considerate consideration i don't want
to give it to the rest of the plane
nobody does that it's amazing but if
you've ever been over to asia which is
incredible is there's so many people
there that you understand that that okay
this is how we're living so we we have
that and i think you know with every
area of the world you can learn
something i'm kind of like you know it
would be cool because i remember before
the pandemic when you get on a plane you
see sitting next to some guy just
and it'd be like it'd be great if this
guy was wearing
you're just saying like oh so this is
what my life's gonna look like in three
days
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
me
[Applause]